many of us may be still sleepy from
those turkey dinners as thanksgiving
celebrations wind down i know we are but
this weekend also marks an opportunity
for world travelers to visit vegas for
the first time in two years as covid
restrictions were lifted earlier this
month sasha loftus joins us live from
the las vegas strip tonight where a
whole lot of people are out and about hi
sasha
hey there brian yes we spoke with people
from all over the world tonight since
thanksgiving is an american holiday
international travelers took it as an
opportunity to come here and see
everything vegas has to offer
that was part of the blessing
tis the season for family fun and all
the thanksgiving fictions
but we do live in las vegas after all
and many are using this year's
festivities as an excuse to head out and
have some fun we plan on coming each
thanksgiving the strip was packed
thursday night as thousands of
international travelers made their way
to our city to soak in all the sights
really pretty excited we got a liver
over there
and this is especially monumental as it
marks the first major holiday since the
recent lifting of a nearly two-year
federal ban on foreign flights due to
covet 19 restrictions
with british airways and virgin atlantic
celebrating the return of nonstop
flights from london to vegas earlier
this month
now people from all over the world say
they're happy to take advantage of the
option to visit safely we can
really see how you celebrate the seasons
and holidays and tomorrow black friday
and potentially start a new turkey day
tradition
here in the entertainment capital of the
world we'll be back next year
definitely
if you plan to travel this weekend at
all triple a predicts about 53 million
people will hit the road and head out of
town also something to note the majority
of the garages and parking lots at
mccarran airport were full as of
yesterday so make sure to plan ahead
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now